[Musique]
salez
5 heures bienvenue dans les celtes et
sammer 2013
les terriens de ce soir sont anne
hidalgo
al hilal gaumont soir vous êtes ici ce
soir dans le cadre de nos émissions
bilan de l'année pour tordre le cou à
une rumeur qui a couru paris tout
l'hiver vous auriez eu une liaison avec
françois hollande
c'est vrai que nous a appelé pour savoir
si c'était vrai
j'ai une vie très sage hva la très sage
si marié cervelle jean marc germain
c'est un bel âge voilà autre terrienne
avec nous ce soir enora malagré
enora bonsoir votre bilan sera vite
faire
révélation de l'année en vigueur
alors on aura en tant que révélation de
l'année j'étais obligé de nous révéler
quelque chose ah bon ouais c'est sûr ça
met
[Applaudissements]
autres terriens avec nous ce soir
laurent ruquier
ok bon soir il est ici ce soir dont on
peut faire le bilan de votre saison et
nous parler de votre nouveau livre on
préfère encore en rire qui rassemble vos
textes de début d'émission de on n'est
pas couché mais si on a déjà payé la
redevance le livret gratuit où il faut
venir
d'abord ce ne sont pas que les textes la
vision son 6e de la radio d'un sur la
déjà payé la pub de repas ça marche
d'accord donc vous avez pris votre
agrafeuse vous avez fait un livre
exactement la ja graff mon cas
et enfin mustapha el atrassi
alors vous ça vous êtes vous aussi si ce
soir pour faire le bilan de la saison
vous n'avez toujours pas été expulsé
vers le maroc toujours par ni envoyé à
guantanamo rien c'est un bilan positif
en p3 prennent aux amis de gaspard
proust nous accueillerons notre invité
du samedi 20 heures ce soir nicolas
vanier l'aventurier qui a traversé la
laponie la sibérie et l'alaska avec ses
chiens voilà l'émission s'appelle scène
italien et le groupe les gréement de
fortune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'explique le principe de
l'émission
donc durant cslt d'été nous allons
retrouver pour devrait donc pas dans un
best-of des invités qu'on a aimés
pendant la saison ses invités seront
soumis à des interviews infernale mais
auparavant nous ferons avec un petit
bilan de leur saison voilà je commence
avec vous laurent ruquier rome on soir
alors on est ici ce soir parce qu'après
on a tout essayé on va s'gêner on ne
sait pas tout dit on n'est pas couché on
n'demande qu'à en rire vous publiez un
livre intitulé comment un peu plus des
titres qui commence pas
le livre s'appelle on préfère encore en
rire il est publié aux éditions du
cherche midi et il rassemble des textes
des stand-up que vous faites au début de
on n'est pas couché votre émission du
samedi soir sur france 2 vous avez
déclaré les mauvaises langues un peu
jalouse prétendent parfois que certaines
séquences de mes émissions ne font pas
d'audience je leur fait un joli pied de
nez en leur montrant qu'elles peuvent
même faire un livre ouais je trouve que
la séquence marche bien et que catherine
barma vous la connaissez catherine je me
dis l'europe continue continue
l'audience montrent cependant que tu
fais ça donne quoi
donc j'ai bien aimé le texte consacré à
anne hidalgo
bertrand delanoë lui a ouvert un
boulevard pour les élections mais entre
les couloirs de bus les voix de vélos et
les embouteillages pas sûr qu'elle
arrive jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville
vous préférez alors ont cessé sur
hollande hollande a plu il plaît
beaucoup moins mais il pleut encore
c'est un peu moins valables
alors on passe au bilan de la saison
maintenant donc on n'est pas couché
meilleure saison depuis la création des
missions faites gaffe parce que si vous
faites trop d'audience sur france 2 ils
vont vous virer souvenez-vous de ce
métal ce qui m'est arrivé à moi écoutez
franchement c'est vous qui devriez vous
méfier s'ils virent aux deux c'est
peut-être moi qui serai ici la basse et
c'est ce qui m'a dit
mon enfant
en télé bilan très positif pareil en
radio on va se gêner cartonne sur europe
1 je possédais 14e saison non oui on va
entamer la 15e saison et en septembre
c'est vrai enora vous rejoindra parfois
ça doit vous changer d'être recruté par
un animateur qui veut pas vous sautez
nous
ne croyons pas sa mort parce que l'état
donnerait trouve super roulé
[Applaudissements]
je ne mangeais pas là aussi bien
rouillée dans mon équipe merci à non
franchement je pense c'est vrai que
d'habitude bravo
je vais déjà vu rouler
[Rires]
alors votre théâtre le théâtre antoine
ça va aussi très bien inconnu à cette
adresse s'arrête pas et lui qui dit
évidemment élu voilà une heure de
tranquillité avec luchini ça ça reprend
la rentrée c'est beau un ballet pas à
strapontin de libre moi j'y suis allée
j'étais au fond de la salle avec un
poteau de vente
ce qui était derrière vous on dit la
même chose
[Applaudissements]
alors on vous êtes tellement star que
france 2 a fait un documentaire sur vous
réalisez pas en gérant millaire alors on
apprend que votre labrador s'appelle
ultimo ça se tape portant ça fait plus
boîte ça dommage autre nom de chien nous
avons trouvé est alors on apprend dans
ce documentaire vous êtes pacsé avec
benoît oui c'est vrai donc même pour
faire chier frigide barjot j'ai pas
envie de vous marier qua non c'est
écouter ça n'est pas prévu si on le
faisait on l'a préviendrait parce
qu'elle serait capable d'être témoin
puisqu'elle a été témoin manifestement
de nombreux mariages avant le mariage
soit autorisée alors peut-être qu'elle
dirait oui allez savoir si en plus on
cherche à se loger la cherche à
déménager il paraît qu'elle ait de la
place chez elle l'instant est ce pas
pour peu de temps encore vous êtes dur
commence mais voilà la loi c'est la loi
la loi c'est la loi
horvàth maintenant laurent la partie
négatif du bilan
on ne demande qu'à en rire france 2
l'arrêté
il y aura quelques prime
[Rires]
directeur studio ici ya longtemps que je
connais thierry mais je vous avais
jamais vu aussi beaucoup
rien à dire c'est parfait nous on a fait
trois ans et coûté c'est bien on a fait
découvrir des humoristes on va revenir
c'est super bowl fallait continuer on va
on va continuer on aura des prime
pendant ce qui n'est pas interdit qu'on
dit
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible que vous soyez là en
janvier n'est pas interdite aux orateurs
où il s'agit poursuit aulas pour
maintenant on va passer à l'interview
formaté avec un grand classique pour
vous le rôle clé l'anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
hop
si vous étiez un défaut têtu et têtu
parce que je le lis beaucoup
une injure pour une femme se serait tu
fais même pas bander strauss kahn
[Applaudissements]
avec un mais pour un homme j'emprunterai
une injure qu utilisent parfois pierre
bénichou et non m quand tu vois ta
tronche et la guillotine je suis du côté
de la guillotine
soutient khosla pau serait suffisamment
malins pour mieux camoufler d'abord en
étant président de reporters sans
frontières
vous étiez un vice la jalousie ah oui
appelait autrefois maladie de travail
leur
[Applaudissements]
c'est une trahison c'est pas moi j'ai
pas de nouvelles d'eric besson vous en
avez maintenant
je vis un poison un intervieweur way une
[ __ ] je serais heureux de l'être je
prends ça je prendrais ça comme un
compliment
j'étais un dictateur un diktat seconde
belle [ __ ]
éducateurs allez je prendrai peut-être
pinochet parce qu'au moins le nom était
rigolo oui
vous étiez un virus j'emmènerai moi mon
ordinateur
si vous étiez un terroriste si j'étais
un terroriste
franchement vous cela changerait de nom
si
vous étiez une torture le supplice du
pal ouais on est [ __ ] ou au départ
si vous étiez une perversion à reste
intéressant
mais surya et et ont
tué terreur sous les 1
sous
enora malagré re bonsoir
en
général et 32 ans est bretonne et vous
confirmer contre l'amoco cadiz et le
dise de nolwenn leroy c'est une région
qui a beaucoup souffert
d'accord on passe à la partie positive
du bilan alors d'abord touche pas à mon
poste l'émission de cyril hanouna sur d8
graff à cette émission vous êtes devenu
la star féminine de la chaîne l'autre
solution c'est roselyne bachelot en
charge des civils alors après avoir été
la présentatrice la plus sexy l'année
dernière cette année vous êtes
révélation de l'année donc c'est quand
même une absence je gagnais un cerveau
un temps incroyable on vous confond plus
avec cécile de ménibus
non mais j'ai dit que j'aime beaucoup
derrière moi m'a jamais confondu avec
kevin ça va ouais super alors vous dites
qu'il est votre grand frère c'est ce que
vous aimeriez qu'ils comprennent en fait
non
non c'est vraiment alors dans votre
famille les femmes est étonnant sierre
de barra marin ouais finalement touche
pas à mon poste c'est un peu ça vous
reprenez le flambeau de la famille c'est
complètement ça complètement salle et a
vu l'élection de gueule et parce
qu'envoyer bien que deux filles
moi je suis là en permanence oui c'est
vraiment le sait le bar oui on va chez
james et vos coups de gueule dans
l'émission est ce que vous pourriez
pousser un coup de gueule contre les
gens qui pousse des coups de gueule
web fait chier à toutes ont violé tous à
tous on vous vénèrent pour tout et
n'importe quoi c'est bon là
alors elle aura bientôt la scène donc
vous dites des humoristes très connu un
prêt à mettre le pied à l'étrier
il est sûr que c'est bien le pied bien
étrillé
oui comment on en parle un petit peu en
vous en parle on m'a demandé un peu des
devoirs de vacances donc je vais écrire
dix minutes et voir si ça me prouve du
plaisir ou pas c'est pas certain alors
on passe maintenant la partie négative
du bilan
rien
waouh ça mais j'avais un numéro
[Musique]
là et laurent passe maintenant interdits
formater un grand classique pour vous
l'interview première fois
[Musique]
m non
premier souvenir j'étais en vacances
avec mes grands parents je devais avoir
4 ou 5 ans à six fours à côté de toulon
oui alors qu'ils sont bretons mais il
m'avait emmené dans le sud bassin la mer
qui piquent première idole madonna ouais
afu première bagarre super jeunes hyper
bagarreuse ah bah oui forcément j'ai été
élevée dans une école de marins-pêcheurs
donc ça castagne est donc il fallait il
fallait représenter un peu riz au lait
coûte foudre 14 ans alors qu'en dise
elle s'appelait c'est une fille ouais
c'est joli ça m'excite
premier baiser sur la bouche sans la
lampre baiser sur la bouche avec la
longue c'est ce qu'en disent c'est
candice et après c'est pierre antoine
très rapidement c'est ensemble
que je vais lui demander pendant ma foi
à 3 donc oui effectivement pas pad pas
de pas de ça non ce que mes parents
regardent arrive aux parents rôdeurs ou
trop
arrêté non premier chagrin d'amour et
non
à cet art 1 vous êtes suicidé en
plusieurs fois ou avec et toutes sortes
de choses une équerre
c'est ridicule
première cuite à ces jeunes 16 ans
bretonne donc à ces jeunes normands avec
mes parents le temps premier pétard
saison ouais ouais la première chose que
vous faites le matin en vous réveillant
je râle
tout seul coup de gueule du tour est
votre dernière volonté si vous deviez
mourir là maintenant que que ma mère
soit heureuse que que tout pour ma mère
qui se passe des choses super pour ma
maman
voilà jeté leurs armes
toner 2013 on se rappelle avait là
dessus
[Musique]
bonsoir et et ayem vraiment sur les
terres on va bien venue lors slt sommer
compagnie d'anne hidalgo
enora malagré de laurent ruquier et de
mustapha el atrassi
anne hidalgo roman ça sert conseiller
régional ile-de-france première adjointe
au maire de paris et candidate à la
mairie pour 2014 secteur vous pensez
qu'une hétérosexuels à la tête de la
mairie les parisiens sont prêts je pense
que ce après son prêt avec ça tu m aimes
ça même sa mère une femme il faut alors
on passe tout de suite au bilan parce
que votre bilan est très positif
evans était désignée candidate
officielle du ps à la mairie de paris
avec 80 18,2 pour cent des suffrages si
ça marche pas à paris pour ce show est
salée au gabon
mais non mais c'était un vote des
militants
alors bertrand delanoë vous a adoubé ce
n'est pas gagné parce que debbie penser
à dave comme successeur
moi j'aime beaucoup bertrand delanoë
parce qu'il laissera le souvenir d'un
maire irréprochable oui irréprochable
café musée de la vie wallonne ou alors
il est plus fort que les autres non
c'est un fait attraper non irréprochable
alors votre programme vous avez prévu
quelque chose pour le l'immobilier à
paris ouais j'ai prévu bien sûr le
logement ça sera le sujet de merouane
c'est cher d'habiter par un lien nous on
a la chance de trouver assez facilement
des logements mais j'imagine weeks c'est
assez compliqué pour le commun des
mortels une tente quechua au canal saint
martin c'est une fortune
l'ambition était d'ailleurs quand on est
mort fois que c'est très difficile place
bien oui mais on y arrive quand même pas
être délocalisés dont la mort y en a
plein qui me demande ça c'est marrant
avait une autre idée aussi c'est
d'agrandir les emplacements de parking
pour que les femmes puissent faire plus
facilement des créneaux
moi la première
j'ai même pas conscients
voilà et alors les vélib donc il paraît
que 12% des gens qui prennent des vélib
sont dopés
d'ailleurs on les bois il fonce dans les
couloirs de bus et les bus ont peur et
puis à l'éternel problème des crottes de
chien parce que c'est quand même plus
simple d'éviter mines en afghanistan une
crotte de chien
je pense qu'il faut faire quelque chose
pour les animaux de compagnie moi
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient des
endroits dans les parcs pour les chiens
pour voilà ça c'est indispensable je
peux intervenir très bientôt en gambie
après un truc qui manque à paris il n'y
a pas de chaque nom ça c'était un choix
qui avait été n'est pas normal dans
toutes les villes jusqu'à quand mais le
sacré je suis désolé je suis désolé il y
aurait des sacs à crottes ce serait des
pratiques pour tous les chiens je suis
pas d'accord avec ça parce que le sac ça
voudrait dire allez-y vous pouvez faire
n'importe quoi aux chiens aux chiens
bien si grande justesse à
présent et pendant qu on vous tiens on
trouve plus de buzz sur paris
alors face à vous dans la course à la
mairie de paris donc la droite propose
nkm nathalie kosciusko morizet elle est
à 35 % vous à 37 c'est la partie moins
positifs du bilan on a quand même un
pour l'instant je fais la course en bois
été et je compte bien continuer jusqu'au
bout comme ça vous avez de la chance
vous envoient leurs primaires c'était
épouvantable et qu'on pouvait même voté
pour grégory lemarchal même si
georges moustaki a voté tout est dit
alors on passe maintenant la tam formaté
en situe sur mesure pour vous c'est une
interview viva españa
[Musique]
comment est à anne hidalgo est sereine à
rennes tettey kembo libyenne oui
viennent olé olé olé
photo x
hakimullah
jo no soy marineros son capital
la politique à mach d'où l'eau non si
elle sera bannie qui chante espagnol est
malade la bamba vous nous avez seulement
y aura de paris si le sud à l'annoncé de
ce palais sinon cela
possible alcalde ce n'est pas dit ce
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils pensaient hd nathalie kosciusko
morizet
la saumonade versera des
motos automobile au in paris
est un peu d'italien la danse
et des massias est tout ouïe bonita tous
les abonnés
la nième fois de leïla c'est mr steve
hansen
se casse à la conférence est ce parce
que rio mais coustalat fait la fiom
la falaise mucho 14
[Rires]
août chocolat et ma discothèque à damas
a la playa
bah moi ça la playa y caliente le sol
non
viva españa bellechasse bise à glace
alors à mustapha el atrassi re bonsoir
nous avons toujours ce petit cheveu sur
la langue c'est sûr c'est pas un poil
c'est un petit poil de cul qui traîne
aussi
très bien alors il est chargé pour vous
donc la fin de la nuit nous appartient
sur comédie plus nrj 12 votre nouveau
spectacle au splendid et en tournée vos
vidéos sur le net les attentats de
boston vient des charges mais quand même
alors on commence avec la partie
négative donc arrêt de la nuit nous
appartient pourquoi j'en avais marre que
poser des questions à des cons de la
téléréalité puis voilà moi j'ai les
bouger les beaux projets la scène
justement on arrive aux côtés positifs
bilan votre nouveau spectacle
télérama a écrit une aisance incroyable
un sens de l'improvisation in et un nom
ou plutôt un prénom à retenir télérama
dès qu'un arabe n'est pas terroriste ils
l'aiment
c'est que j'ai encore rien fait exploser
ouais pour l'instant sauf votre talent à
moncao
on regarde le classement
on a des gens qu'on les teste et ce que
j'aime vraiment pas cessé les vieux qui
veulent absolument avoir l'air jeune on
sait qu'ils veulent pas vieillir on les
voit tous dans confessions intimes c'est
mon fils c'est trop mon poteau non
dégueulasse données one sweet way
challenge et l'ouest
donnez-lui du champ oui
elle a du kebab sous les ongles fait
quelque chose
son vernis c'est ça la tomate oignon
c'est une telle charge que je me suis
demandé si je ne devais pas avorter mais
on m'a dit c'est trop tard il marche
y'a pas longtemps j'ai joué j'ai lu un
article qui regroupe les recherches les
plus celle où sur google et ça fait
flipper on vit dans un pays qui fait
peur il ya des gens qui tapent des trucs
inspecteur gadget
fait la vaisselle
comment s'appelle un bâtiment où se joue
un opéra
qu'est ce que voit un aveugle
et enfin mon préféré cerise groupama
sextape
perval atrassi sur scène posture en
ville à battre 18 septembre
alors votre rêve disiez vous dans votre
premier spectacle c'était de jouer au
foot et de faire rire les gens en même
temps comme le psg c'est sa maison ni
kelavan le qatari les qatari et les
qatari ratatouille justin bridou là une
burqa dans six mois je te libyenne ne
s'arrête plus on va passer d'un tel ou
formaté vous avez - vous marrer
qu'est-ce qu'ils interviewent gratitude
j'ai quelqu'un est très reconnaissant on
va voir n'est pas marre de voir tout le
temps laurent ruquier à la télévision
non je trouve qu'on le voit pas assez
vous trouvez comment le monologue de
laurent wauquiez au début on n'est pas
couché un peu court
ou 10 points les chroniqueurs de on
n'est pas couché quand il n'est pas là
laurent un setter éviter basse et les
trucs sur ta soeur en général sur le
timon non non non il a non les gens sont
très sympas il a quelque chose de très
dur il sait être très dur
non je ne parle pas de ça
mais quand on travaille au travail
vous êtes vraiment dégueulasse eux
sa fin il paye bien non ok on a un peu
radin non ils payent très bien il va et
très bien en quoi vous est il déçu lors
des six jeunes arrivent pas et décide
cette personnellement il m'a vite en
vacances il me paye moi je l'avion grâce
à lui j'avais jamais goûtez-moi ça
soulage c'est bon la fiancée
délicieusement la berge et conseille à
tous les pauvres qui nous regardent
d'essayer un jour éventuellement il sait
bien s'entourer vous pensez que seule
leur et autant de succès il m'a dit une
fois qu'ils prenaient des gens qui
étaient capables de faire des choses
dont lui était incapable ouais donc je
cherche toujours pas pourquoi il m'a
pris
six mois je sais très bien je te laisse
certes effectué une passe à compliment
c'est pas du tout il intervient
gratitude ses interviews cire-pompes la
même évidence elle avait su jouer vient
d'avouer chapon vous trouvez pas qui rit
un peu trop de ses blagues à l'huile en
ok je suis un connard en fait dans mes
réponses non est ce que tu trouves pas
qu'il est un peu trop mais elle est
tellement quelques ou
non on voit les noms ce que tu veux je
ne supporte pas ce mec c'est une mère
[Applaudissements]
et
je sais je
- travers brûler des taux avec des clubs
sis à
mousse oui qu'est-ce qui t'énerve le
plus c'est lui plus il vieillit plus
embellie physiquement mais plus il est
chiant
vacances et arabes est-ce que vous avez
déjà lu content de travailler que
laurent ruquier non j'ai vraiment c'est
toujours été un beau c'est avec vous ça
a été plus compliqué
on passe maintenant au dossier de la
semaine avec l'édito de blacko et c'est
le spécialiste du monde arabe samuel
laurent que nous retrouverons sur ce
plateau après le magnéto
on mars 2011 quand sarkozy a attaqué la
libye la majorité des français a appelé
deux tiers d'entre nous étaient d'accord
pour bombarder kadhafi
certes trois ans auparavant le méchant
dictateur était l'invité d'honneur de la
république mais entre temps bien des
choses avaient changé en tunisie la
foule avait renversé ben ali en egypte
que la foule avait renversé moubarak
alors en libye ont autant soutenir la
foule qui tentaient de renverser kadhafi
[Applaudissements]
surtout que les libyens détiennent la
plus importante réserve de pétrole de
toute l'afrique ce qui les rend d'autant
plus sympathique malheureusement les
choses ne se font pas passer tout à fait
comme prévu deux ans après la mort de
kadhafi la libye est aujourd'hui
totalement déstabilisés par les
affrontements entre milices armées qui
disputent le pouvoir le sud du pays est
devenue une zone de non droit ce qui
permet aux groupes djihadistes de
proliférer et d'étendre leur influence
dans tout le sahel en janvier françois
hollande a donc dû lancer une nouvelle
opération militaire pour que le mali ne
tombe pas aux mains d'aqmi
les jihadistes ont subi des pertes
importantes mais ils ont encore assez de
moyens pour déstabiliser la région il ya
eu la prise d'otages d'une raffinerie en
algérie cette nuit dans un bain de sang
depuis l'attentât contre l'ambassade de
france en plein tripoli ou encore l'
attaque contre une mine d'uranium
exploitées par areva au niger
rétrospectivement on se demande d'autres
c'était vraiment de suie bonne idée que
ça d'aller bombarder kadhafi
on serait tenté de dire que non sauf que
sans l'intervention française cas dati
s'accrocherait peut-être encore au
pouvoir et comme bachar el-assad en
syrie yg azereix les populations civiles
en combattant les groupes armés
islamistes et là ce serait pas forcément
mieux que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est l éviction de blacko mise en image
de julien gracq pas si en allant bonsoir
bonsoir monde arabe et vous avez publié
sa liste en position du seul bienvenue
parmi nous nerveux de votre job c'est
d'aller dans les endroits les plus
risqués de la planète pour le compte des
grandes entreprises internationales pour
voir si des investissements porteurs
sains et fiable c'est comme ça que vous
avez été amené à voyager en libye avant
et après la chute de kadhafi lorsque
vous dites aujourd'hui sur la libye et
que les médias ne disent pas c'est que
les progrès enregistrés depuis la chute
de kadhafi sont inexistants ils sont
pires que ça ça fait deux ans qu'on vit
dans l'auto congratulation avec la libye
ça fait deux ans qu'on est content de
tout ouais on est content de la
révolution on est content des élections
on est content d'un gouvernement que
bernard henri lévy continue de qualifier
de démocratique il dit voilà les
islamistes sont pas arrivés au pouvoir
donc en permanence on est content de
tout ce qui se passe en l'occurrence en
recul alors on va prendre les points un
par un ouais l'islamisme radical
prospère al qaïda aqmi l'anarchie ouais
un règlement de comptes violent
torturent meurthe exactement firmes et
les milices qui ont gardé les armes
fournies par la france c'est les alliés
pour combattre kadhafi mais aussi des
stocks d'armes voix la majorité à
kadhafi ce qui fait que les raquettes se
multiplient les trafics en tous genres à
commencer par la drogue maintenant les
dealers ont un accès limité année
c'était quand même plus simple quand on
est dealer les armes un même les
missiles sol air le racisme donc c'est
la honte de cette révolution elle est là
vous avez d'un côté les arabes et de
l'autre côté les noirs et les noirs sont
traités pire qu'au temps de l'apartheid
c'est un véritable de wallace et les
massacres qui sont organisées en toute
impunité dans les villes du sud est
voilà les tabous mais pas seulement au
nord vous avez par exemple la ville
portait aux nues par par bernard henri
lévy quitter misrata misrata a considéré
qu'il y avait une ville à côté de 80000
habitants qui s'appelle taouarga qui
était une ville noire qui avait soi
disant soutenu le régime elle l'a vidé
et la massacrer ses habitants elle a
brûlé les maisons en écrivant des
slogans mort aux [ __ ] et c'est surtout
tenir et ça fait deux ans que les
survivants n'ont pas le droit du [ __ ]
un pied c'est un génocide ans et voilà
exactement c'est un pur génocide parce
que quand vous prenez la définition du
génocide on est en plein dedans bien sûr
alors donc la guerre de sarkozy et
bernard henri lévy un plonger la libye
dans le chaos et personne n'ose en
parler en france en fait la personne
n'ose en parler parce que c'est un
terrible embarras pour nous on a plongé
dedans parce que c'était une guerre de
com pour sarkozy et c'était c'était un
délire pour bhl enfin moi je comme ça
bon il avait un peu raté son coup depuis
voilà depuis la yougoslavie depuis
l'afghanistan et a vu le darfour et
c'est ce déballage me refaire rien c'est
un peu comme au casino et le gars et
s'est dit moi je me réfère et là il a en
effet il a tout eu c'était le coup rêver
personne ne pouvait saké kadhafi dans le
monde arabe il n'avait aucun allié il
était détestée de tout le monde c'était
la cible idéale sait on est rentré
dedans à pieds joints sans réfléchir que
c'était un très gros foyer islamiste
primo on le savait le graphite tel truc
mais enfin les deux sont liés verrouillé
c'était un samedi où le dictateur laïque
ont été menacés par elite nature
théocratique d'ailleurs exactement à la
première erreur c'est d'avoir su dès les
imposteurs du cnt davout une clique
d'incompétents et d'opportunistes qui
conduisent le pays à la ruine mais en
fait le chaos ça sert leurs intérêts il
ya deux personnes qui tiennent le cnt
enfin au départ et on décide de les
nommer le premier c'est abdel jalil
c'était le ministre de la justice de
kadhafi c'est lui qui avait condamné les
infirmières bulgares et ce qui est
hallucinant parce que voilà sarkozy va
nommer à la tête de la révolution le
type qui a justement condamné deux fois
entérinées deux fois la condamnation à
mort des infirmières bulgares quelques
années plus tôt voilà et 2e ccj briquet
on appelle ça en arabe on appelle ça
c'est un grimpeur c'est à dire les types
qui viennent et qui se colle aux
révolutions ont baissé en un
révolutionnaire pas du tout quelques
mois vont ils travailler pour ces faits
l'islam à son conseiller économique
c'est un homme d'affaires il travaille
pour le fils de kadhafi ouais alors
conséquence de tout ça c'est ce que vous
dites dans votre livre c'est listant qui
est excellent je le précise merci
thierry naissance d'une zone d'influencé
des terroristes qui couvre désormais une
surface plus grande que l'europe
occidentale tout entière
que vous baptisé unsa et listant enfin
c'est à dire un afghanistan près de chez
nous exactement même à la rigueur c'est
beaucoup plus qu'un simple pays parce
que la région après par effet de bas par
effet de contagion s'étend sur le mali
s'étend sur le niger une partie de la
mauritanie risque de s'étendre également
une partie du chat bon set c'est très
vaste à et toute cette région
aujourd'hui et sous le sans le moindre
contrôle alors conséquence bas invasion
du mali par des groupes islamistes
exactement avec les stocks d'armes que
la france avait utilisé contre kadhafi
plus les stocks d'armes de kadhafi donc
hollande a été obligé d'intervenir
la différence c'est que c'est que
sarkozy est vraiment responsable
d'ailleurs là vraiment c'était une
guerre qui ne qui ne fallait pas faire
dans ces conditions hollande était
obligé d'intervenir mais là on peut lui
reprocher quand même c'est de ne pas
être intervenue plus tôt parce que on
est huit mois pour les surveiller pour
regarder comment ils avançaient comment
ils se regroupaient comment ils s'arment
et où est ce qu'ils sont et ray et
qu'est-ce qu'ils préparaient comme plan
de sortie on n'a rien fait on n'a rien
fait et on a attendu qu'ils poussent
plein sud et donc qu'ils prennent
l'offensive qui prennent la main pour se
dire là on va réagir alors un hidalgo
risque finalement on a raison
d'intervenir dans ces pays est ce que ce
fameux droit d'ingérence
prenez par bernard kouchner n'est pas du
néocolonialisme et qu'est ce qu'on en a
à [ __ ] en libye si les libyens
venaient en france pour s'occuper des
affaires françaises on trouvait ça
grotesque je voudrais pas que la
conclusion soit finalement les
dictateurs avait raison il fallait les
laisser là oui c'était parce que on
avait quand même à faire à des
dictateurs il ya eu des révolutions les
peuples se sont soulevés et en libye ça
a été plus compliqué parce
qu'effectivement et c'était beaucoup
plus tenus peut-être encore que le
hockey en egypte mais je pense que
on ne peut pas aboutir à la solution
selon laquelle finalement les dictateurs
n'avait qu'à rester et que tout allait
bien puisque effectivement il s'occupait
des isley tout à fait d'accord mais là
n'est pas mon propos n'ont donné pas mon
propos sur le mali l'intervention était
plus clair c'est vrai puisque elle a mis
du temps mais parce que on voulait pas
intervenir tout seul il fallait que ce
soit quand même dans le cadre on est
quand même en salle vous en conviendrez
même aujourd'hui on est quand même très
sale mais en même temps l'idée n'était
pas d'avoir une intervention
unilatérale de la france sans que ça ait
pu être discutée au sein des instances
de l'onu non je ne connais pas aussi
bien le dossier que monsieur mais en
tout cas il ya deux de réflexion que je
me fais en entendant ça c'est d'abord
c'était quand même incroyable que
sarkozy
effectivement décide d'éliminer kadhafi
après l'avoir reçue comme un déçu
quelques années auparavant ça c'est la
première chose qui me choque dans cette
affaire aux trois pour le reste il me
semble que de toute façon les
révolutions c'est un peu toujours comme
ça c'est le bordel après dans un premier
temps une fille même de se reporter à
quelques siècles chez nous il ya eu la
terreur après la révolution et se sont
ils ont commencé à guillotiner entre eux
donc voilà je suis un peu comme ça une
révolution avant que ça redevienne une
démocratie normale il faut à l'aps
est-ce que ça redeviendra une démocratie
n'entamèrent fait en tout cas si vous
croyez au journal sens de l'histoire
progressiste oui mais comme on n'est pas
obligé d'y croire là il faut les laisser
faire en tout cas oui c'est ce qu'on
aurait dû y être manifestement il y
avait une il y avait une rébellion il y
avait des avait quand même un type qui
faisait tirer sur son propre son propre
pays son propre peuple je peux
comprendre qu'on ait eu envie de nourrir
et des opposants et il fallait et il
fallait si on souhaitait intervenir
fallait mettre ses opposants ce soit les
laïcs ou les islamistes parce qu'ils
représentaient tous deux une part
importante de la civil du pays le front
national dan pas confondre qui était
qu'ils étaient eux les libéraux et les
démocrates et puis le front islamique
libyen de combat qui étaient les
islamistes purs et durs il fallait les
mettre ensemble et leur dire voilà vous
représentez x % de la population y % de
la population et vous êtes à même
à bas c'est toute la question c'est bhl
est allé sur place excusez moi je
tout est de la faute de l'échec écoutez
il exige autre chose il est allé en
libye et il a fait un casting il a
rencontré voilà les deux trois
dirigeants qui étaient là et qui se
présente est autoproclamé qu'il ya
autant responsabilité que ça à londres à
l'entendre sur l'assemblée sur c'est
hallucinant ça montre la fragilité de
sarkozy qui peut se faire prendre
est gênant n'est pas grave et qu'il
était fâché en tout ça servait quand
même beaucoup
c'était un peu le jouet de nicholas
willis a servi pour tous qui avez pas
d'organiser l'organisation
internationale l'onu a été totalement
défaillant si vous aviez pour finir un
mot à dire à bernard henri lévy vous lui
diriez quoi je les vues de trois fois
dans des interviews parler de la libye
raconter des choses fausses parce que
peut-être il n'avait pas en face aux
répondants de gens qui pourraient
rentrer dans les détails et lui dire non
là ce que vous dites c'est faux donc je
dirais je vais vous souhaitez ces deux
rencontres ah oui j'aimerais j'aimerais
beaucoup en débattre bernard shaw
regardes tu es le bienvenu voilà merci
ça ne nous avec nous c'était la p2 jeu
les celtes et summer 2013 françois après
la bûche avec le japon
la pause est notre invité du samedi
nateur ce soir nicolas bazire
l'aventurier filles à travers ciel
si guéret la nascar avec ces chiffres
a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors à mon sens les terrains non mon
fontaine aurait bien vu dans les celtes
et sonneurs 2013
en compagnie des noms ramallah gros
de laurent ruquier
mustapha el atrassi
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir nicolas vanier
bonsoir
un vannier enfants vous rêviez de
devenir trappeur dans le grand nord
traversant la taïga la toundra la
banquise avec des traîneaux à chiens au
milieu des loups et des grizzlies vivant
de chasse à l'élan philosophant avec les
indiens et puis vous avez décidé de
réaliser vos rêves d'enfants c'est fait
vous raconterai vos exploits à 20h dans
un instant gaspard proust mais d'abord
le zapping
c'était le zapping et maintenant jacques
à gaspard proust pour l'été de gaz cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
monsieur cousin marseillaise et gaspard
proust un baltringue est parisienne oui
monsieur additionne ces summer et on
s'adapte avait l'accent c'est plus
marrant disponibilité gentillesse
flexibilité mais surtout à l'esprit
comique affûtait de la tête coquillettes
aujourd'hui j'aimerais dédicacé ma
rubrique art marseille la belle rebelle
mondialement connue pour être la plaque
tournante du chômage internationale
est-ce que marseille a beaucoup à
apprendre la france marseille c'est une
mosaïque de diversité des différences de
nos similitudes d'antithèse de
contradictions le contraste de
disparités disproportion de dissemblance
de dissimilitude de distance de
distinction de diverger ans d'écart
d'hétérogénéité des compatibilités
d'inégalité des nuances eu de variétés
et c'est là où ça reste mon dictionnaire
du cim
retour de ma vie où tout est ambiance
des raisons et surprise tient au débotté
d'une re qu'est ce donc que cet
attroupement de métro sexuel prostituée
qui s'ignore et du salarié triste mais
bon ça c'est bien sûr sur le plateau de
plus belle la vie
voici donc quelques conseils pour passer
un bel été l'été c'est le thème des
noyades bon
quand vous voyez un homme qui est dans
une piscine ou à la mer et qui crient
s'il vous plaît attention c'est pas
forcément un rom
ces gens là n'ont pas le monopole de la
politesse
non peut-être que la personne vous
montrer qu'elle aime être regardée comme
tel cool
respecté dit tu coules c'est cool
[Applaudissements]
il se peut que ce soit c'est rare mais
bon un appel au secours et que vous ne
savait pas nager se pose une question
qu'est ce que vous foutez la plage
un tellement que de lucidité sur ses
propres
aptitudes en devrait vous faire quitter
immédiatement les lieux foutez le
prévenir les secours bien sûr que non
sinon comment ils s'en foutent ces gens
là on n'exerce pas la truffe du cochon
truffier en lui montrant où elle se
trouvera
le rôle des secours c'est de deviner ce
qui peut se passer respecter ce travail
mais l'été c'est aussi le soleil on dit
qu'il faut se protéger balivernes
bagatelle e billevesées calembredaines
coquecigrues fadaises de fariboles
niaiseries et sornettes et c'est là où
s'arrête mon dictionnaire des synonymes
autre conseil de vacances
les moustiques problème avec les
moustiques c'est qu'ils ne comprennent
pas c'est que patron il faut des
représailles mais comme dirait notre
ministre de la justice à la [ __ ] oui
mais d'injustice
[Applaudissements]
aux côtés moustiques que vous attaquez
soyez vigilants soyez à l'écouté
chercher à deviner ses trajectoires
compte et mentalement le nombre de ses
battements d'aile pour évaluer le poids
il va venir vous piquer et dans combien
de temps et 20 banques il attrape boom
immédiatement tu me suces le seul qui
vient de boire tuyaux crache à la gueule
et tu lui dire c'est pas bien ce que tu
as fait
certes la violence ne résout pas tous
les problèmes mais elle al'avantage de
diminuer le nombre de personnes qui leur
causent
autres mais sciences de l'été
les enfants toujours laissé sans
surveillance mais qui gambadent les
pauvres couillons qui se perdent qui
prennent la route ces [ __ ] plus aulas
qui dans 15 ans ne croiront que le bas
que leur ouvrira les portes de serre
[ __ ] des générations qu'ils aillent se
faire enlever vers des contrées comme la
belgique oui si le secours populaire
permet à de nombreux enfants du nord de
rejoindre les plages du sud la
pédophilie permet de nombreux enfants du
sud de visiter les caves du lent
mais bien sûr
cela s'appelle la curiosité
intellectuelle
et il vaut mieux commencer tout
autres petites choses qui peuvent
arriver et me cause de des plages
faut-il en avoir peur la réponse de
bernard de la villardière est très clair
si c'était me cause de droite ça me
plaît
plus sérieusement un bien sûr faut pas
avoir peur
non non c'est le début
une mycose c'est quand même la
possibilité d'avoir un animal de
compagnie à faible coût et d'une
fidélité sans faille mycoses europe y
est tu n'as pas bougé
et limicoles je pense tongs mais on ne
dit pas tant que mes claquettes la tango
fait tom la claquette fait crac
la pétanque
toujours à pratiquer sous un soleil
torride l'éternel problème de la
pétanque le cochonnet à ne pas confondre
avec la boules de geisha la barre des
coupoles de sa femme
car attention si pierre qui roule
n'amasse pas mousse fameux qui rebondit
fini dans les orties
[Applaudissements]
je termine par un petit sondage sondage
d'été il paraît que les françaises
veulent valls pour une nuit montebourg
pour les vacances et j'ajouterais sa
peine pour l'éternité
foire aux jouets
vous aussi vous pouvez suivre l'actu de
l'émission réagir sur twitter via le
compte les terriens et le hashtag slt on
passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20 heures
nous convenir bonsoir bonsoir disette et
le 5 mai 1962 à dakar au sénégal père
employé de banque mère femme au foyer
vous ne restait que quelques jours au
sénégal et vous grandissez en fait en
sologne dans la ferme de votre grand
père c'est là que vous découvrez le vrai
contact avec la nature votre grand père
vous transmets l'art de débusquer le
gibier d'évaluer l'âge d'un cerf avec
les bois ou piste est une compagnie de
sangliers dans l'apprentissage très
précis j'ai des souvenirs comme ça de en
automne par exemple d'aller la nuit à la
découverte des cerc ibram dans la forêt
c'est assez magique ça c'est
préhistorique un vrai rêve d'enfance ont
bercé par les histoires d'indiens de
trappeur de bêtes sauvages
d'immensité blanche est hostile vous
lisez jack london fait dix morts cooper
herman melville oui je
ne veux lire que des romans qui parle du
nord mes parents me disent que déjà
l'âge de 6 ou 7 ans lorsque je regardais
une carte du monde je ne voulais
regarder que le haut de la carte moi
c'est quelque chose que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir toujours eu en moi
une sorte d'appel comme le disait si
bien jack london l'appel du grand nord
est ressenti ça très tôt alors là j'ai
17 ans avec deux potes vous monter dans
un train gare du nord et voulant
redescendre et que 36 heures plus tard
au terminus à kiruna en laponie suédoise
donc au delà du cercle polaire et là
vous avez 60 euros en poche donc il faut
pêcher malheureusement c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de pêcher en laponie qu
en sologne bah oui parce qu'on se donne
il suffit parfois de poser sa canne pour
avoir un brochet en laponie il ya
beaucoup de poissons mais
le poisson répond parfois à des
exigences un petit peu bizarre au point
de vue climatique est haute et on pose
de la can est une truite et puis tout
d'un coup baisse des températures est là
qu un poisson votre première vraie
expédition c'est le canada vous dites là
quand vous arrivez croc blanc existe un
en revanche qui n'existe plus ce sont
les inuits de votre enfance est très
déçu ça vous marquera longtemps parce
que voilà il fume des cigarettes ils
boivent de l'alcool ils prennent de la
coke et y circulent en motoneige quoi
produits c'est-à-dire les ravages qu'ont
pu faire cette sorte d'humanisation
qu'on a appelé des indiens qui a été
absolument dramatique parce qu'on a
cherché à les faire entrer dans notre
siècle par des portes qui n'étaient pas
bonnes et sont aujourd'hui dans l'alcool
dans la drogue un taux de suicide
inégalable inégalée et c'est vrai que ça
fait partie des choses qui m'ont
profondément marqué alors labrador vous
entendez parler d'une expédition en
traîneau à chiens et à force de
l'harcèlement vous serez intégré à
l'équipe vous allez parcourir 1700 km
dans la taïga la toundra la banquise ça
a été une découverte absolument
extraordinaire de l'hiver des chiens de
cet univers les loups les caribous
extraordinaire les berrichons suivante
renoue avec l'histoire des grands
pionniers de l'ouest vous fait 7000 km à
travers les zones les plus sauvages des
montagnes rocheuses et l'alaska un an et
demi de voyage je remonte à cheval en
traîneau à chiens ensuite en radio et en
canoë toutes les montagnes rocheuses je
traverse tout alaska hélas ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que pour la
première fois je vis la succession des
saisons pour complètement m'immerger
dans cet univers qui dans lequel je me
sens de plus en plus chez moi quoi alors
ce qui est terrible c'est calme en vous
êtes surpris par la neige est obligé de
marcher devant les traîneaux pour dames
et la piste à neige est profonde et pour
pouvoir tracts et des traîneaux chargé
de 200 parfois 300 kg de matériel de
nourriture notamment pour les chiens eh
bien il faut effectivement se mettre en
avant des traîneaux et en raquettes
tasser la neige pour faire une sorte de
couloir à l'intérieur duquel les
traîneaux vont suivre et donc cédé des
heures et des centaines parfois des
milliers de kilomètres en raquettes mais
c'est plus du plaisir qu'une souffrance
parce que une fois l'entraînement prix
c'est extraordinaire que d'être comme ça
en raquettes de marque faire cette piste
ça mange quoi les chiens de traîneau
ça mange soit de la viande si on peut
s'en procurer soit de la nourriture
déshydratée qu'on emmène avec soi c'est
pour ça que je parlais tout à l'heure
d'un entraîneur très lourdement chargé
ensuite il expédition transsibérienne
alors là malgré la pérestroïka vous
allez beaucoup de mal à obtenir une
autorisation de la part de l'ambassade
du rss et comme vous y tenez absolument
vous souvenez vous avez un ami d'un ami
qui connaît françois mitterrand et là
vous traverser la france en 4l pour
aller le convaincre j'arrive avec ma
vieille 4l dans la cour de l'elysée il
l'appelle mikhaïl gorbatchev et mikhaïl
gorbatchev en personne me signe un visa
en me donnant ce qui paraît c'est
totalement hallucinant russe et au
sibérien un port d'armes de façon à
pouvoir tout de même traverser la
sibérie avec un fusil pour pouvoir
chasser éventuellement de défendre des
animaux sauvages qui peut y avoir ici et
là il faut s'imaginer qu'en 90 c'était
un coup de bluff absolument
7000 km en sibérie
à ya un proverbe qui dit en sibérie
l'hiver dure aux douze mois le reste
c'est l'été quoi ça j'ai pu m'en
apercevoir sur glace mais c'est surtout
un un pays extraordinaire avec une
nature absolument désolés au réal les
loups hurlent et vous vous êtes obligés
de rester près de vos chiens parce que
les loups ne s'attaque pas en fait à
l'homme mais s'attaque aux chiens parce
que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'une
meute de loups et très territorial et à
partir du moment où en traîneau à chiens
vous entrez dans leur territoire c'est
comme si une meute de loups concurrentes
venaient ce et donc les loups du coup
viennent à votre rencontre c'est pour ça
que j'ai vu immensément énormément de
l'eau dans ma vie mais il faut faire
très attention parce qu'ils vont de
façon systématique à battre les chiens
si vous fait pas acte de surveillance
auto alors dans les villages vous
arrivez la nuit la vodka coule à flots
au delà de l'alcool ce qui symbolise
c'est surtout l'amitié la fraternité
effectivement même s'ils n'ont que une
bouteille de vodka dans tout le village
pour un an ils vont l'ouvrir ce soir là
alors au bord du lac baïkal un frappeur
vous fait cadeau d'un chien qui
s'appelle coach wim et vous allez avoir
une relation magique avec ce chien en
fait c'est oui le nom d'une petite
peuplades qui a disparu au bord du lac
baïkal que je donne à ce premier chien
qui va devenir le mon premier chien de
traîneau et c'est un chien avec lequel
même
15 ans 20 ans plus tard trente ans plus
tard je parle avec beaucoup d'émotion
parce que c'est un chien avec lequel
j'ai pas eu une relation humaine je suis
pas du tout du genre à vouloir humaniser
les animaux mais qui a été un animal
avec lequel j'ai une complicité
extraordinaire qui a été le chien de
tête
avec lequel j'ai fait de grandes
aventures vous je crois plus de 30000 km
en traîneau à travers tous les pays du
monde et lorsque ce chien m'a quittée et
partie une grande partie de ma vie est
partie avec lui ouais c'est pas moins
traversée de la sibérie que vous
rencontrez le peuple est vaine alors si
les inuits sont détruits par l'alcool et
se déplacent en motoneige les evènes
demeure extrêmement authentique c'est
une vraie bombe que j'ai reçus en
découvrant ce peuple qui vit totalement
à l'écart du mont-dore plein milieu des
montagnes verdoyantes sa 8000 km de
moscou ils n'ont pas d'argent la seule
chose qu'ils ont ce sont des reines ce
sont avec eux qu'ils se déplacent avec
il s'habille avec le guide se
nourrissent toutes leurs richesses sont
les rem un peuple qui vit totalement en
harmonie avec leur territoire qui
construisent depuis des millénaires une
relation avec la nature qui me fascine
et donc je vais rester avec le passé une
nuit vous reste des chinois vous devenez
très ami avec nicolas et le chef du clan
et qui vous donnera la responsabilité
très importante en fait de garder le
troupeau de rennes menacé par les loups
et le jour vous trouvez pour la première
fois en train de garder le troupeau de
rennes c'est une responsabilité terrible
pour vous je comprends à ce moment là
effectivement quelle est cette espèce de
relation très ambigu de ces éleveurs de
rennes ont vis-à-vis du loup qui est un
animal qui à la fois attaque lorraine et
qui est un animal qui les fascine aussi
totalement parce qu'ils ont compris
depuis longtemps puisqu'ils sont à leur
contact que ce sont des animaux
extraordinairement intelligent et ça va
être la naissance d'un roman qui va
devenir ensuite un film long métrage que
je vais aller tourner avec eux ensuite
vous partez en colombie britannique avec
votre femme et votre fille qui a 18 mois
vous passer l'hiver dans les cabanes en
rondins que vous construisez vous vivez
de chasse à l'élan de pêche en canoë et
à un moment on fait un manteau en castor
à votre fille avec des boutons en bois
oui on a vécu totalement en autarcie
pendant plus d'un an et pour l'habiller
pour l'hiver pour se défendre contre les
grands froids de l'ordre de - 40 moins
50 parfois puisqu'on a ensuite traversé
toute la région de uconn jusqu'en alaska
en traîneau à chiens je suis fabriquer
des vêtements à partir de ce qu'on
trouvait sur place alors quand on vous
dit que c'est inconscient de faire vivre
en enfants dans ces conditions vous
répondez cas moins 40 chapa de microbes
et que c'est en arrivant à l'aéroport
que votre fille a chopé un
oui c'est un petit peu symbolique mais
c'est vrai que
pour moi un milieu hostile c'est paris
c'est pas le grand nord moi c'est un
espace dans lequel je suis chez moi
et j'avais envie de partager avec les
miens ma femme ma petite fille cette
passion ce bonheur qui a été le nôtre de
vivre pendant un an dans cet univers ça
a été une année extraordinaire ma petite
fille a appris à parler dans les
montagnes donc ces mots c'était chien
s'était tant des cabanes et lorsqu'on
est ressorti de la montagne au bout d'un
an elle avait par exemple aucun mot pour
voiture donc c'était un très beau qui
roule une maison c'était une grande
tente en face c'était dans une année
merveilleuse en griller une expédition
vous aurez du mal à terminer c'est le
grand nord canadien d'ouest en est huit
mille six cents kilomètres en 100 jours
ce qui m'a fait faire une des moyennes
de 80 à 100 km par jour dormir quatre
heures maximum par 24 heures sur quatre
mois d'affilée le reste des heures est
en accoucher à vivre dehors à -40 moins
50 milliards eu des moments
exceptionnels mais il ya eu aussi où il
détrône deux fatigués difficile les
indiens vont aider il ya une chaîne de
l'amitié qui s'est construite avec les
indiens les inuits tous ces petits
villages qui s'égrenaient tout au long
du parcours absolument extraordinaire et
lorsqu'ils ont appris qu effectivement
j'avais des difficultés ils ont organisé
une sorte de relais pour pouvoir d'un
village à l'autre ouvrir des pistes me
faciliter la progression
des tas de poissons parfois de phoques
ou de caribou qui m'attendait pour
nourrir les chiens enfin c'était
émouvant parfois aux larmes de voir
cette espèce de chêne qui s'est mise en
place et quand vous êtes arrivé
plusieurs milliers de personnes vont
acclamé j'arrive sur les champs-elysées
du québec sur la terrasse du château de
frontenac enneigées pour l'occasion une
autoroute fermée 200 policiers mobilisés
ding complètement dingue aujourd'hui
vous publiez belle et sébastien chez xo
éditions puis d'aller voir le film sur
tout oui j'ai voulu redonner vie à cette
série qui se meurent déjà un petit peu
dans les archives de la télévision
française d'une série en noir et blanc
qui m'a bien évidemment à mon époque ému
comme des millions de français c'est
avec une passion immense que je me suis
lancé dans ce projet qui est du sur
mesure un petit enfant
un grand chien blanc la montagne c'est
du sur mesure le film sort quand le 18
décembre le 18 décembre ça tombe bien
c'est une très bonne date merci merci
votre témoignage voilà c'était elle
c'est l'été summer 2013 votre tour de
l'été
avec anne hidalgo candidate à la mairie
taille 2014 et son livre mon combat pour
paris chez flammarion enora malagré
tons marron dans touche pas à mon poste
sur des lits et sur virgin radio à 21h
tous les genres plus de temps en temps
tu remportes chez laurent ruquier
laurent ruquier
de retour à la rentrée sur europe 1 et
france 2 en attendant on peut lire son
livre on préfère encore en rire ces deux
éditions du cherche midi moustapha
à partir du 18 7 ans avec son nouveau
spectacle
samuel ans pour son livre
quant aux éditions du seuil et nicolas
vanier pour benzema siens chez xo
éditions et le film dans le 18 décembre
merci merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à
faire cette émission rendez vous ici la
semaine prochaine salut les terriens
je
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus